what is up everybody at Santa Mack here
for anime uproar and today we will be
taking a deep dive into the newest
developments in the seven deadly sin
story and specifically the ongoing
massive battle between the demon king at
full power and the seven deadly sins
after patiently waiting for quite a
while we finally got to see an
increasingly important character in
action against the demon king for the
very first time and the fate of zeldron
and all of Britannia is currently on the
line by the way a big thank you to all
of you who follow these videos every
week thank you for watching thank you
for leaving a like commenting and so on
that really means a lot to me and now
let's get into the good stuff just
remember that we are gonna be dealing
with the most recent events in the story
so manga spoilers will be coming proceed
with caution you have been warned and
don't forget to subscribe to anime up or
if you do enjoyed this type of content
and you want to see more and of course
click that notification bell so you get
notified when we upload if you don't
click the bell YouTube will basically
completely bury the channel and you
likely won't even see it now chapter 3
to 3 starts off with malleolus and Gotha
facing off against the fake gelda inside
the spirit world and the fake gelda is
still holding Zelda's captive using some
sticky spider web stuff Mellie Otis
calls out to celtris and celtris slowly
wakes from his slumber he asks Mellie
Otis why he is here and Mellie Oda says
that he is here to save him
predictably the fake gelda tries to
convince el dress that malleolus is a
liar and that he actually killed her out
in the real world but zelgius reveals
that he knows that this gelda isn't the
real gelda he was hoping that she was
real he wanted her to be real but del
just knew this gal that was a fake
because she keeps saying how much she
loves him and adores him but zelgius
says that the real gal that would never
say such a thing to him now we know that
the real gelda does indeed loves el
dress and that she is determined to find
him no matter what however we don't
actually know much about her personality
so my guess is that gelda doesn't have
the kind of personality that's just
lovey-dovey with zelgius and talks to
him about how much he loves him all day
long I'm guessing that she is more of a
badass girl who likes to joke around and
tease him instead of just being romantic
all the time and that is how zelgius
knew that this gal dot was not
real I could be wrong but that's what I
was thinking while I was reading this
part of the chapter this revelation
leads to the fate gelda evaporating and
a huge fog engulfs the whole area as the
demon king calls zelgius a fool who
chose to walk the same path as his
brother Mele otis and Gotha rushed to
find zelgius in the fog but they come
across dozens of different zelgius
clones hanging from the weird sticky
stuff that the demon king is using to
restrain zelgius all the different cell
juses call out to Mele otis to save them
and go thermally otis are unable to
determine which cell drous is the real
zelgius meliodas
already emotional because of his brother
loses his patience and decides to just
cut every string that is holding all of
the various cell dresses unfortunately
meliodas is so agitated and anxious to
help Zell dress that he doesn't wait for
Golder to explain to him that if he
makes contact with anything in this
world even just a string he will be
immediately ejected back into the real
world if that happens he won't be able
to find celtris at all so goal third
throws himself in front of Mele oldest
in order to stop his sword lost Wayne
from making contact with the strings but
the force of the impact throws Golder at
one of the Zelda's clones and because
they came into contact Golder is ejected
back into the physical world as Mele
Otis apologizes to Goethe her for being
so rash and hitting him in the process
go thorns him that he must discern the
real zelgius from the fakes meliodas
remains in the spirit world on his own
as go through wakes up in the real world
where the demon king is still fighting
against the sins bond king and Eska nor
are leading the charge as merlin hangs
back and protects the others using
perfect cube the demon king seems as
confident as ever and king s Kannur and
bond don't seem to be capable of taking
him down on their own this is saying a
lot because we know how strong bond King
and s Kannur are right now especially
together as a team back when the demon
king had possessed meliodas s can or
didn't even have sunshine so bond was
forced to do most of the heavy lifting
on his own at least on the outside while
meliodas was fighting against the demon
king on the inside currently the demon
Kings power level is definitely
extremely impressive since he seems to
be actually gaining the upper hand
despite being severely outnumbered
however in
that moment gelda the real gelda sneaks
up on the demon king and bites his neck
with her vampire fangs Elizabeth and the
others are shocked to see this and they
are especially terrified when the demon
king seemingly easily decapitates gelda
with his sword he then proceeds to call
her sneak attack nothing but a trifling
interruption at first everyone assumes
that gelda just set a new record for a
character getting inste wrecked in
battle but it turns out that gelda is
not dead her head and body fused back
together as she thanks the seven deadly
sins for fighting the demon king and
allowing her to sneak up on him and
drink some of his blood
apparently the vampires have incredible
regeneration abilities and now that she
has consumed some of Zelda's blood
through the demon king who is of course
using Zelda's body as a vessel
gelda becomes stronger and is able to
recover easily although her hairstyle
has gotten looser in the process so now
you know that she means business gelda
reveals to the demon king that her bite
wasn't intended as an attack apparently
now that she is connected with Zelda's
blood she will be able to enter the
spirit world and meet up with Zell dress
and malleolus there since Gotha doesn't
seem to be involved in this I'm going to
assume that this is some special vampire
ability the ability to enter someone's
soul once they come into contact with
their blood this is sort of consistent
with traditional vampire lore along with
drinking blood being forced to avoid the
Sun and all that usual stuff vampires
have long been portrayed as having
strange psychic abilities as well even
Dracula and Bram Stoker's famous novel
has the ability to use hypnosis and
command other vampires and even some
humans and animals to do his bidding
Delta's ability to enter Zelda's his
soul and make contact with his
consciousness after making contact with
his blood in the outside world appears
to be naka Pazuzu keys take on the
psychic aspect of vampiric power back on
the inside in the spirit world Melly
Otis is still unable to tell which is
the real Zell drous then Zell drous
presumably the real Zell dress tells
meliodas to just kill him along with
their father because zelgius would
rather die than give his body for the
demon king to use this makes sense
because we know from previous chapters
that zelgius wholeheartedly disagrees
with the demon Kings way of ruling the
demon world and he definitely wouldn't
want his
body to enable the demon king to keep
wrecking havoc across the different
realms but meliodas tells him that no he
doesn't need to kill him because he is
going to save him and after all the real
gelda is still out there waiting for him
so he cannot give up now then just as
zelgius prepares to tell malleolus a
final message that he hopes in malleolus
will deliver to gelda gelda herself
appears in the spirit world and tells
elders that she wants to hear the
message directly from him all the dozens
of zelgius look up at the same time as
geld appears and vows to find the real
zell dress herself the chapter ends
there and i know that some people might
be thinking why did we just spend a
whole chapter focusing on gelda instead
of focusing on the epic fight between
bond s kannur and king versus the demon
king but as I mentioned in previous
videos Delta will definitely play a
major role in this battle gelda must be
to want to get zelgius to start fighting
against the demon king on the inside
otherwise this battle cannot end well
for the sins if they kill the demon king
they also kill Zell drous but if they
don't kill the demon king they will
continue to expend their energy on the
battle and because the demon king
doesn't have the same restrictions about
not killing he will use any opening he
can to destroy the sins without mercy
so gelda has to play the role of
motivating Zell dress to join the battle
from the inside just like manly Otis had
fought demon king from the inside back
when the demon king was possessing him
that is the only way to end this battle
in a way that takes care of the demon
king without killing Zell dress in the
process and by the way this is all
assuming that the demon king doesn't
have yet more tricks up his sleeve or
that the supreme deity won't show up at
some point whatever happens we also
can't forget that noon is coming soon so
SK Noir is sure to take advantage of
that but going all-out may also lead SK
North's body to give out on him and we
have to remember that because he is
trying to save zelgius meliodas hasn't
been using anywhere near his full power
if in the next few chapters malleolus
and gelda managed to rescue Zelda and
Zelda starts fighting the demon king on
the inside I think it's all over for the
demon king the only way that the tables
could turn again is if the demon king
somehow receives another massive powerup
or if we have another total GameChanger
like say the supreme deity actually
showing up on the battlefield let me
know what you guys think is gelda going
to
Childress and will that be it for the
demon king or can we expect even more
twists and turns along the way twists
that might involve new surprise
power-ups or other characters like
Arthur the mother of chaos or the
supreme deities showing up on the
battlefield let me know down in the
comments I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this topic if you enjoyed the seven
deadly sins content on this channel
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
please don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell you can follow me
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest seven deadly sins
news and updates I want to give a huge
thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons for supporting our work and
making our work possible a special thank
you to all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
zelgius and on Hell crews another
massive thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray ace
ingrid ah al Olin Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun and Keylong and finally at
the very pinnacle of interdimensional
greatness a tier reserved only for
legends a massive thank you to Regan
Harrison and Lord Noxon or disciples Oh
Lord to ego himself if you feel that our
content provides value for you when you
want to support more be sure to check
out our patreon link in the description
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]